- I usually talk about
obsessions on my show.
I hear you have one with murder mysteries.
- Since I've been like 12 years old,
I've been fascinated with why people do
what they do and don't
do what they don't do.
Isn't that interesting?
I mean if you really can figure out
why people do the things they do,
and don't do the things they don't do,
you got a real leg up on the world.
- Yeah, you can figure
out how fix that crazy.
- And other things.
- So you devoted a whole
podcast to these mysteries.
What does that say about you?
That you like murder?
(laughs)
It's a whole podcast.
- You better hope that's not true.
- No, you'd know how to get away with it.
- Well no, you figure
out why people do this,
then you can figure out ways to keep 'em
from doin' it, right?
You can figure out how to
stop this from happening.
How to spot 'em before they do it,
and, cause you deal with things,
like the one I'm the one I'm doin' now is
about Chris Watts, the family annihilator.
He just killed his pregnant wife
and his two little girls.
- And he didn't give any reason?
- Well, he's givin' 'em now.
- Wow, okay that would
be interesting to hear.
- Yeah, exactly.
And, you know, your story
goes a whole lot better
when you're the only one tellin' it,
and as soon as people
started asking questions,
he folded up like a pup
tent in a windstorm.
He just, bang, he just gave it up,
and now he's in, he'll be in
jail for the rest of his life.
And he's destroyed all of these lives
for absolutely no reason.
- That's what I'm sayin',
but you're gonna find the reason, right?
That's the whole point, I love,
that's so scary but interesting.
I don't know, that kinda
stuff really trips me out.
I can't watch Dateline, I
can't watch any of that stuff.
- Well, you don't wanna
listen to this podcast.
- Maybe I won't, maybe you
come with like a fun one.
Like a fun podcast, like
one where people live.
(laughs)
I'd love to go deeper,
would you be willing
to let me analyze you a bit more?
- Oh listen, if you're
willin' to go in here,
- I'm ready.
- Listen, you don't wanna get in here.
- I'm ready, I'm not afraid.
Let's step into my office,
let's do it, let's do it.
(applause)
You are obviously on the couch.
I mean, your legs are gonna be really high
in this seat, it's a very high seat.
Is that how they are in the,
yeah, I would fall asleep in therapy
if this is what it looked like.
They'd be like open up,
and I'd be like (snores).
- You sure this is a trip
you wanna take, sister?
- Mhm, yes, yes brother, let's do it.
Okay, so when was the last
time you really cried?
- I'm crying inside right now.
- Oh, so you're
uncomfortable around people,
okay, okay, okay.
What's the one thing in life
you're still trying to find?
- My hair.
(laughs)
I swear, I swear
- Here, you can borrow mine.
- I went to bed one
night, and it was there.
- You can borrow mine.
- Thank you.
(laughs)
- I found this lovely little
piece, you look beautiful.
You look beautiful, anyone can have hair.
What is the one thing
- I went to bed one
night and it was there,
and I woke up the next
morning, and it was gone.
- Me too, that's why I'm
wearin' weave, brother.
It's gettin' thin.
- I've been bald since I was 12.
- That's all right, it's tough, I like it.
- I read one time that 78% of
me would amputate a body part
rather than be bald.
- I know one they wouldn't to be bald.
(laughs)
It's useful.
What is the one thing you'd
tell 16-year-old Phil?
- What'd I'd tell 16-year-old Phil?
Boy, you are gonna love your life.
(laughs)
- I love that answer, I love that answer.
You realize you're
blessed, that's awesome.
- You're gonna love your life,
and you're gonna love your woman.
- What's the one trait of yours
that you'd like to change?
- One trait of mine I'd like to change.
I talk so damn slow.
- Do you know that that's
- Is there a, is there a
fast forward button here?
Like, spit it out, boy.
- Wait, you know what I feel
like when I'm on The Voice
with Blake Shelton, cause
that's how he talks.
I'm like, get there.
- And he does it from higher up,
so it takes longer to hit your ears.
- Yes, you do too, I'm so short.
Yes, he takes so long to say one sentence
with seven words.
- I would talk faster,
but then there are times
when I get goin' and, you know,
people think at 12 to 1400 words a minute,
and talk at 125 words a minute,
and Robin will sometimes gust up to 160,
but I talk at about, I
talk at about 80 or 100,
so I think we average out
between the two of us.
- She's, Robin's like me.
What's the secret, actually,
what's the secret to being
married for 43 years?
(applause)
- Well, there's a couple actually.
- Okay.
- I learned that whenever she says what,
it isn't that she didn't hear me.
(laughs)
She's giving me a chance
to change what I said.
(laughs)
So, you need to recognize
those opportunities.
- Oh my god, I totally do that.
- I married her for her looks,
but not the ones sometimes
I get in the kitchen.
(laughs)
- Those are the fun looks.
- You can ask her, what's
the secret, 43 years?
- Oh, it's okay to tell
a lie once in awhile.
- You know what?
That's truth, I'm writin' that down.
That's truth, I used to be so against it.
- Like are those new shoes?
Oh no, I've had these old
things for 20 minutes.
- Final question, will you stick around
for the rest of the show?
- Do I have a choice?
- No; what?
- I would love to stick around, yes.
- What?
- Yes, yes.
- Great, don't forget to watch
Dr. Phil weekdays, y'all.
Check your local listings.
We'll be right back with
the beautiful Lacey Chabert.
(music)
All right, y'all, we're
here with Dr. Phil McGraw.
My next guest was the iconic
Gretchen in Mean Girls,
love fetch, so fetch.
Now she's the raining Christmas queen
of the Hallmark Channel,
her latest movie is called
Christmas in Rome, take a look.
- Now the dough is easy to make.
Just watch me and follow along.
Take the oil,
and then the salt,
then we will add the flour,
slowly, add the flour.
You know what?
Your method works too.
- Please welcome the lovely
Lacey Chabert, y'all.
(upbeat music)
(applause)
- Hey everybody.
- I'm in love with your dress.
So good.
- So nice to meet you.
- How you doin'?
- Right over here.
Man, that dress is so rockin', I love it.
- Thank you so much, I appreciate that.
- It's just such a cool dress too.
- Thank you so much, you look lovely,
and it's so nice to see you all.
- Have you ever met Dr. Phil?
- I don't think we've ever met before.
- I don't think so.
- Nice to meet you.
- Have you ever done therapy?
This is an intervention, is that weird?
I'm just kidding.
- You know what, we got lots
of things to talk about.
- I'm totally kidding, have you ever,
I've actually done therapy.
- I have, I think it's super helpful.
I think therapy sometimes is
obviously it's with a professional,
sometimes it's with girlfriends
and whoever's willing to listen.
- Yes, but it is nice to have
somebody outside your circle
to really just, whew, lay it out there.
- Someone that's unbiased,
that's so important, and
you can say whatever.
- Or they can judge you,
but you don't know them,
so whatever, yeah, judge away.
- They can't tell anybody
else they're judgin' you, so.
- Exactly, I don't know you.
So, since we have Dr. Phil here,
can you help sort out anything,
do you need anything sorted out?
- Yes, I have come here today because,
I mean, I put this in my wedding vows
because it is such an issue
in our relationship, that
- I'm so excited.
- I know we may never
disagree on the TV station,
the radio station, or the
temperature in our home,
and I will learn to live with that.
But let me tell you, I cannot deal
with the temperature part.
My husband is very
anti-conditioner, I'm always hot.
When I was pregnant, I
was like get a sweater,
leave it on.
So what do I do?
- Turn it down, cause listen,
he can put on a sweater.
Screw 'em.
(applause)
- Here's my thing, in
defense of your husband,
I feel like my house is a meat locker.
Everyone's like I feel
fine, I'm in like a parka.
Like, my house is so cold.
- You want it cold right?
- Just cool, just a normal
temperature, yes, just cool.
- We keep it so cold and put
so many blankets on the bed
you gotta get out to turn over.
(laughs)
- So, you've done, I just found out,
is it 19 Hallmark movies?
That's crazy, that's a lot of work.
You must love working with them.
- I love working with them.
You know I've been in the
business since I was seven,
so I've been doing this a long time.
And I've worked with a
lot of different people,
a lot of great people, but
they very much what the,
you know, the values that
their movies emulate,
they are like that as a
company and as people.
And I'm so thankful to
work alongside them,
they've become friends.
- So Christmas in Rome, right, that's the,
it's your eighth holiday
Hallmark film, right?
- My eighth countdown to
Christmas movie, yeah.
- That's amazing, did you love it?
Is this a good one?
- I did, it's such a fun one.
You know, we try to
make each one different,
and special, and while the
messages are all very similar,
this one was particularly fun
because I get to go to Rome,
and my character lives there,
and she's a tour guide,
and it's her passion to show
people this beautiful city
in a way that they've
never seen it before.
So she encounters Sam
Page, who plays Oliver,
wonderful actor, and he's
there on a business trip
and doesn't really plan
on seeing the city.
So it's her mission to show
him what Rome is really about,
what's at the heart of it.
- Oh I love it, she's passionate about it.
Do you love Christmas, is that
why you're in eight films?
I love Christmas, we said it in sync.
That was crazy, we were in unison.
- I love Christmas, I love it.
I love decorating for Christmas early,
although like, total confession,
because I've been busy
making these movies,
I haven't been, I gotta up my game again.
I kinda dropped the ball.
- Girl, I've wrapped 75%
of our presents already.
- Have you really?
- Not a joke, I don't play, I don't play.
I don't have any time off,
so when I do, I've got
Christmas music goin',
wrappin' in my dinin'
room like a crazy person.
- And I love your Christmas music.
- Oh, thank you, oh thank you.
I love Christmas music,
oh my god, I'm with you.
So what's Christmas like
at the McGraw house?
- Should we confess?
- Yes.
- When it comes that time a year,
- If you say you don't like Christmas,
I'm gonna smack you.
- No, listen.
Tell me if I'm lyin',
we record every Hallmark
Christmas movie every year,
and watch every one of 'em.
I'm serious.
We've watched every
movie you've ever made.
- Are you serious?
- No, I'm serious.
- I'm so flattered.
- More than once.
- I think we've still got
like 30 of 'em recorded
on our DVR.
- It's a tradition.
- We like binge watch 'em,
we've seen every one of your movies.
- I'm so flattered, thank
you, that's so nice.
- We love 'em.